ethan so i don't know what was happening
he had something else on i think
chair you know lives thank you tom
uh well good evening uh fellow
councillors uh ladies and gentlemen
joined us on
we're starting a meeting now of full
extraordinary full council meeting
of the 29th of march and
the first thing we have is uh apologies
for absence
and register so whichever way you want
to do that
is it kirsty yes it is thank you chair
should i do
the apologies from councillor clark and
councillor cottle honkin
christie sorry casey just stopped
councillor carl hunkins arrived at the
meeting
oh okay thank you and i think i'm
supposed to
apologize for coaster ford i don't know
whether he has joined or not
oh he hasn't ken he did ask me
put an apologies if he wasn't
right okay thank you shall i do the
register yes please
thank you councillor belton yeah here
councillor brenton president councillor
bright
president councillor brown president
councillor bushby rosie
councillor christie rosen
councillor cottle hunkin president
councillor craigie
not present thank you councillor dart
councillor gov present
thank you councillor hackett president
councillor haynes president councillor
harding
president councillor hawkins
president councillor heppel
president councillor hicks president
councillor hudson
hear me councillor hudson
no councillor hurley president
councillor hutchins yeah chancellor inch
he's trying to get in i'm just giving
him the code
thank you councillor james president
councillor jones president
councillor langford president councillor
laws
present councillor leather here
councillor lock present councillor manly
present councillor mcgoff
no he's not present kirsty thank you
councillor mackenzie
president councillor newton
present counselor pennington president
councillor rossi
no he's not present thank you councillor
watson
councillor wiseman yeah bestie
uh councillor dart has also joined us
lovely thank you
right thank you christy so item two then
his public contributions i understand we
don't have any this evening is that
correct steve
uh that's correct thank you three is
declarations of interest well you know
the rules on that if
we've only got one item ready to discuss
tonight so we've got an interest you
must declare it
uh number four is agreements between
part one and two
now propose that we go into part two the
start of this debate because we're
dealing with a private company
and therefore we have confidentiality to
consider
then uh after we've had the debate about
the way forward
then we'll go back into what part one in
order to
make that decision in the public domain
so um agreement between part one and two
we need to go through that again
to uh to agree that all right
i'll second that chair
thank you chair councillor belton uh for
councillor benjamin point of order point
of order do we
need two votes here one to change the
agenda
and one to go into part two
we've had this discussion before uh
council of pentagon as much as i
i agree with the duplication that sounds
ridiculous we still have to go through
this process i'm afraid
i appreciate it i apologize share thank
you no don't apologize i
totally sympathize yeah kind of
clarified sorry um yeah
we're going into part two to discuss the
report in part two
first is that right so yeah
yeah yeah that's right when we get to it
yeah all right
thank you chad brenton
yeah four thank you councillor bright
paul councillor brown four
councillor bushby or councillor christie
or councillor cottle honking
well it's councillor craig you joined
yeah four thank you councillor dart
paul thank you councillor god
four councillor hackett or
councillor haynes or councillor harding
or councillor hawkins
for chancellor heppell sport
councillor hicks for
councillor hudson joined
yes she has but she looks like she's
frozen oh no she's
councillor hudson can you hear us
no we can't hear you claire
i'll carry on shall i yes please christy
councillor hurley
for councillor hutchins
yes okay thank you
sorry sorry councillor james
paul councillor jones
four councillor langford
or councillor laws
or councillor leather why
councillor lock oh
thank you councillor mackenzie four
councillor newton four
councillor pennington yeah
councillor rossi
now he's not present thank you
councillor watson
for councillor wiseman paul
thank you that's 29 4
1 against and two abstentions chair
thank you kirsten you item five
correspondents i don't have any
corresponding
chair steve is there anything that is
burning
okay no i don't have anything either
okay good
number six and uh questions under
procedural rule
a9 we don't have any of those either do
we
no no that's right okay so now we go to
number seven then which is reopening the
torah
leisure facilities and as i explained
before uh
part of this is commercially uh
sensitive so therefore we'll have to go
to part two for that
and then we'll come out of it when we uh
make a decision so uh
one sorry we have to go through the
procedure again
and uh i propose from the chair that
will go in part two
with secretary for that please yeah all
right go
whoever who was that casper watson
thank you council watson right so uh
we'll go through that again
thank you councillor belton uh four
councillor brenton four councilor bright
four kessler brown four
councillor bushby or counselor christy
counselor christy oh
thank you councillor cottle honking for
councillor craigie oh that's the darts
poor council look up
for councillor hackett or
councillor haynes or councillor harding
or councillor hawkins
for councillor heppel for
councillor hicks for
councillor hudson
no councillor harley
for councillor hutchins
councillor inch four
councillor james paul councillor jones
four langford
four councillor laws four
councillor leather or councillor lock
four councillor manly
four councillor mcguff
thank you councillor mckenzie
four four councillor newton
paul councillor pennington yeah
councillor rossi
right here councillor watson oh
councillor wiseman four
thank you that's 31 four and one against
chair
thank you well